three two run
action
black widow is something that the marvel
universe has
never experienced before the action in
this film
is real you these huge armored vehicles
going through
these iconic streets in budapest
budapest itself is so important to who
natasha really is
and what drives her and she finds this
family from her past there
so we're going to talk like grown-ups is
that what we are
within like two days of knowing scarlet
i was just ramming her into a door frame
all the fighting in this film is so
emotional and
about not knowing how to say what you
[Music]
feel
it's good to see you too sis there's
some of the most
intense fights that we've had in the mcu
there's this big fight scene
in this enormous prison there were 400
extras it doesn't feel like a movie it
feels real
i wanted to create something really
visceral
and fun but to talk about natasha as a
human being
to let audiences see a sign of her that
they had never seen before
i've spent a decade of time with this
character
[Music]
and she's finally able to write her own
story
[Music]
i'm done running for my past